hi steve kaufman here i'm looking for
advice this is about my trip to asia
which i'm going to be doing next march
my wife and i and another couple
we are going to
fly
via seoul
to yangon in myanmar
i've already contacted a travel agent in
myanmar who is going to set up a trip
for us or at least a program visits in
yangon
bagan inle lake back to yangon
and that'll be
basically from march the 3rd
to march the
9th
march the 10th we fly to hanoi so first
part is in myanmar second part
from the 10th to the 18th we're in
vietnam
within that period uh i want to fly to
siem reap to see angkor wat but we
intended just overnight there ten spend
two full days
one night and then fly back to hanoi so
basically
from the
i guess what's available to us is the
11th to the 17th
in
hanoi
excluding these two days they were going
to go to angkor wat and i'm not sure
which we know when we'll do that
so
i would like some advice from
any of you who either live in
vietnam or have traveled to vietnam
what is the best thing to do we
obviously can't see the whole country i
see that there's so much to go and see
dan nang hoya and hue
we can't do it all
and especially if we're also going to
see
something of myanmar so if we're based
in hanoi essentially for seven days but
two days trip to angkor wat or one day
but two fold one night two full days
what should we do uh you read about
sappa you read about
taking a jump trip into halong bay or
anyway i'm looking for advice or even
just to take uh rent a couple of
motorcycles and drive out or get a car
and drive out to a little village nearby
or what is there to do that that we can
explore and get a feel for the country
don't necessarily want to spend the
whole time going through historical
building you want to get a feel for how
people live and
the smells and the sights of of vietnam
looking for advice
and then on the 18th we continue back to
seoul and we're going to have four days
in seoul so again i'm looking for advice
on what to do perhaps a good reasonably
priced hotel which part of the city to
live in
uh i was thinking it might be fun to
take a high-speed train from seoul to
somewhere daegu and back again just to
see some of the countryside but again
looking for
where to stay perhaps some suggestions
of hotels where to go and visit what to
do
march 18th to the 22nd in seoul so
um
going to asia we can't do it all we
can't be in every possible place we'd
love to go to luang prabang and
and ho chi minh city and uh so many
different things but we've decided that
this is what we're going to do we're
going to do three countries in 22 days
and i'm looking forward to hearing
your suggestions of what to do and where
to stay and any other bits of advice
that you can provide
thank you very much look forward to
hearing from you
bye for now